[Music]
in drunk spending news what I hate what
I do that [ __ ] dude you guys drunk often
is I get drunk and we're out with a
bunch of friends I try to pay that tab
all the time yeah it's [ __ ] Korean
things like every time it's like I got
it ah
and the next day I wake up what the [ __ ]
I was like all this wanted money gone
alright so this one is submitted by love
baby bill oh thank you I knew was a
little girl who genuinely said it like
that
and she made a song anyway here's a
little story he's a little story about a
bail about a baker oh my girl oh I want
that song so dances and if that stops
you from using your debit card when
you're drunk I mean that I don't know
anything how that's possible some just
of it or the debit and credit your card
maybe have to put it like directly in
your whole mouth there's this app it's
called drunk pay or drink paint I don't
know because it's BR NK okay pretty much
the way it works is that you will link
your cards that you tend to use with the
app and and then you get to select the
number of drinks that you wish to have
an event for example you to put like
three pints of beer or whatever and then
select the types of payments to block so
for example like from a particular bar
or just plugs in general or food online
shopping or all categories and then
cards are blocked for 12 hours once you
sort that and then there's a
breathalyzer that's connected to the
system via bluetooth that is used before
each purchase to authorize payments so
to make sure you're not too drunk
and then it's the users under their
predefined limits the relevant cards are
then activated and payments can be made
that's kind of like that one thing on
your your Mac or you put specific apps
in there for a certain time that you
can't use what yeah so you could put
like Safari in there and certain
websites that you're not allowed to go
on and so if you tried to like if you
have a TD it helps out a lot so I used
to do that because I like flip on
Facebook or whatever and it's like that
I don't need anymore but I would have a
tendency to always go on Facebook or
some other [ __ ] you know but then it
kind of helped me learn it helped me
learn that how much time I waste what
I'm right so once the once I caught the
habit of knowing that this is the X
amount of time I waste all these
websites it kind of stopped using it now
but what if there's an emergency in
general I can override cause no no no
well it's specific websites on Safari
I'm sorry oh so I would put Facebook
Twitter any B&H all that all that other
[ __ ] Amazon all this stuff on it
spank wire no I haven't heard that alone
oh gee
Mangler he said he already met some
really good memories like everything was
tasty before HD was the thing I don't
know I remember a while back I got on
and it was just like virus central like
everything was a pop-up of a guy I want
it first started no no no this is like
years at got too commercialized
yeah and then everything was a pop-up
and like everything funny malware my god
no more say choir than me
born of it is a wine connoisseur porn
sites mmm no most likely yeah so this is
the present whether it comes with and
then see what the app looks like do you
kind of feel like if you need this app
you should probably just go to like a
alcoholic anonymous means right now it's
got me you gotta carry that around it's
like I don't know like that mentality
drink I think it should be for like
Korean people so many people always be
trying to play the bill all the [ __ ]
time dude especially when they're drunk
they always even when they're sober
that's true I feel like the people who
genuinely need this with never you
mm because like you you have a problem
in you you're gonna want that [ __ ] helps
out though because one of my friends
Marcus a name is Jasper he went to Vegas
and he got so [ __ ] drunk you know
like when you get like bottle service
right like these girls are trained to
pour these drinks down your throat to
make you [ __ ] pay more [ __ ] he woke
up when I don't remember the number
anymore but it was like thousands of
dollars like on receipts because these
girls would sit on his lap have him like
pour the [ __ ] liquor down his throat
and they would just keep happening over
and over and over and they walk away
with a [ __ ] ton of money he wakes up
barf all over with just a huge [ __ ]
crazy receipt BSC like for those
purposes I think would work like I'm
going to Vegas
let me limit myself but for somebody
who's chronically drunk all the [ __ ]
diamonds they spend money they're
probably not going to use that or I can
see people faking it setting all that
[ __ ] up
but before they block certain things
they just go get cash so that it looks
like yeah I've been using mine you
better know what we need we need to app
that forces the people who don't want to
pay to pay that would be a more
effective people not going to include
the packing-case video they just kind of
like they forget that they had a drink
they got an appetizer
there was tip and taxes and then we
thought mom gave me like 10 bucks yeah
it something called taxes you [ __ ]
coming around up in surrounding yeah
they always round down right at $11.99 I
owe you 11 bucks right no she will be
$12 [ __ ] Carly are you 15 yeah
but the passenger yeah she cracks me up
dude yeah it pisses me off because I
always give more than I think I'm
posting yeah just for tip purposes so I
hate when that happens
and then it's like relax seven dollars
short my house yeah because I gave for
five dollars over who's out here so I
felt that because it on group back at
home this is like we're all broken [ __ ]
my friend Kathy she was always the one
to overpay and she would get everybody
and it would kind of pissed me off
because she was enabling whoever those
[ __ ] were to keep on doing it
so we will come up like 20 bucks short
which is impossible because
I would overpay just a little bit you
know just so we can give that person a
good tip and then she would over pay
like another 30 bucks to cover it up at
my command
that's about that shout out to you Kathy
sometimes depending on where you're
dining with you probably want your
separate checks yeah that's me and for
my four homies can we get five checks
please
I don't know Joey you'll figure out who
the [ __ ] is skimping out yeah sure if
I'll ever say that though just like yeah
I know so don't eat whispering don't
have friends no no you know what the
friends are China pay for your [ __ ] yeah
but this app also has a help me out
feature where users can book an
emergency uber to get home Oh as I was
for like a yeah yeah but it is because
it's just it's protecting all drunk
people there's like uber just positive
like drunken sex protection there's like
this thing I'll wake you up in the
morning it's not as crazy drunken sex
particular uber has helped out a lot
though no [ __ ] younger in this arm oh
maybe it was like a face analyzing thing
right but on a second no I got drunk
goggles you buttons love you
that would be funny but it has to scan
your face first and then CS is really
all judges like depending on how drunk
you are you get uglier so know depending
on how ugly you are who they feel is
eatable yeah like you can [ __ ] with this
is within your lane days oh that's such
a good app that'd be tight let's make
that I cannot use you know it's like I
of Dave Hosea you think yeah car
yourself pretty let me take a picture
oh the lap is when that noise come on
that's perfect it's like Oh actually we
can brother texted me again God knows my
dog's bed I got
that's crazy captain regice I have this
compatibility app it reads our knives we
just raised your face when your eyebrows
that's all I need the [ __ ] ribs it's
the eyebrows the angle and the [ __ ]
direction is going to [ __ ]
are they Instagram II know how many
tattoos where's it located perfectly
they say that they also have this if
you're not down to just be carrying
around a breathalyzer with you all this
who does it anyways like people with
serious bring your phone who would be
down actually if you have a DUI you do
have to carry one with you all three
have to carry one or have it in the car
hey you know everything I think it's in
the car actually I just want to know
before you drive it you actually have to
breathe into it company also has a
wearable tip it yes I'm a Fitbit type of
thing that is it monitors how much
alcohol is in your direction
Anil yeah I will Cal for that don't
stick me with [ __ ] no I don't have a
needle but you just say a biosensor that
constantly analyzes the alcohol content
in your bloodstream so how to order now
with like technology I wonder if we're
going so far because before when
technology was invented it kind of
helped alleviate like real issues now I
feel like technology is trying to make
us be super dependent for no [ __ ]
reason you know I mean like there's like
that boundary it's like just control
what you're drinking bro he said to me
and then you'll be fine
you know me it's like that weird yeah
like my car like it drives itself
[ __ ] [ __ ] that though I don't you
know I mean now let's just lie some
other thing out of them it's useful but
I feel like if you go back to your
regular car you gonna be very upset yeah
I was because when my car was busted it
was a little little hard I was a worse
driver because they did a little too
much for me I used to have no problem
rewinding a VHS but that's a videotape
and then and then DVDs came out where
you could just skip there was no way I
was going back to [ __ ] it yes everyone I
was like [ __ ] technology is ruining me
and it isn't getting worse
that does then how do you think about I
was the weird kid I was a queer kid but
ya know I know it's [ __ ] husband hope
you guys enjoyed that episode if you
guys have any juicy little gusts of
details and you guys almost admit it
well guess what you can cruise on over
to the description box below click on
the link submit the story and hopefully
we will pick it and talk about it for
more videos click right over here
[Music]